in a private kitchen in San Juan a group
of volunteer chefs prepare enough hot
food to feed thousands Bastien Ramirez
is a restaurant owner and chef native to
San Juan he lost his business after it
flooded during Hurricane Maria he and
his team are preparing a traditional
Caribbean soup sancocho it's made from
beef stock and root veggies this is what
the response to Hurricane Maria looks
like brigades of volunteers descending
on remote communities where food and
basic necessities are scarce they have
been the most crucial lifeline for the
millions of residents impacted by the
storm
where we going now we're heading to
OOP waddle which is in the central North
mountains of Puerto Rico whoo - adios
high elevation means it experienced some
of the strongest winds on the island
decimating its infrastructure and
because of its remoteness and
significant road damage many communities
are simply unreachable
sebastian's group is coordinating with
Carlos Delgado's Foundation a nonprofit
operated by the former New York Mets
infielder himself
the group splits off into separate teams
we ride with Sebastian to a neighborhood
called Lagaan well spirits are high in
la Granja evidence of the desperate
circumstances is not hard to find
residents line up to collect potable
water and fuel and get their animals
treated at a table set up by volunteer
veterinarians
[Music]
a Puerto Rican doctor asks us to meet a
family down the street their two
children both have cerebral palsy and
they've been without medical care power
or running water for nearly five weeks
[Music]
the father says he spoke with the
National Guard about getting a power
generator which would help
vivianne Hibernia is one of the
countless residents who lost her roof in
the field giant feet came upon the bus
Jeremy Wow a two-way telephone the
completamente power with the majority of
relief efforts focused on basic needs
many wonder how the islands will rebuild
its infrastructure it's becoming
increasingly clear that recovery will be
long and slow raising questions about
how this will impact the island's
economic future
IHS a research and analytics firm
estimates the cost of rebuilding Puerto
Rico to be between 40 and 80 billion
dollars we followed Sebastian to his
shuttered restaurant parse Ella his
story is just one of tens of thousands
of small businesses across the island
that were forced to close up shop and
it's these small businesses that are
make or break for Puerto Rico's economy
when without power since the hurricane
hit and we this the rest one that is at
its close the money I would have to
invest to bring it back up in working
conditions with the situation how it is
it won't be possible you can see up
there like the back wall went out so the
whole kitchen got full of water
everything here it's now clean but
everything up here was full of sand salt
residue water so you boarded everything
out yeah operating my restaurant been
open for three years now so it's only
been a couple of years and now it's gone
yeah it's gone it's been a tough week
before the hurricane we've also been
going through a pretty tough economic
time a record number of people have left
Puerto Rico since the financial crisis
of 2008 tourism has also been in decline
another asset for the island's economy
and for businesses like Sebastian's
probably seeing how around the world
everybody was going back to using local
products
supporting their local economy so I
wanted to come back to Puerto Rico my
Island I saw there was a resurgence in
the agriculture one of the main
producers Sebastian uses is frutas del
Cabo run by Aaron David Robles an hour
from San Juan against the northern coast
his farm was badly damaged and he won't
be fully operational for months
how bad was it I went through who go to
George nothing like this this was just
art of unexplainable Sebastian and Efron
have a tight business relationship with
one relying on the other to make ends
meet what is gonna be the hardest part
just about getting back to where you
guys were we were seven years to get to
where we were so it's gonna be awhile to
get there I work mostly on restaurants
so it I depend a lot on them everything
was level from one end to Puerto Rico to
the other I mean there's no one farmer
that can says that was impacted by it
and it's not just the products his days
for structure is the labor is the bills
dark comedy this is a micro example of
the domino effect Maria will continue to
have on Puerto Rico's economy affecting
not only agriculture and restaurants but
industries like tourism and
manufacturing I didn't plan anything
small businesses struggling since the
storm much like Efron and Sebastian's
are.what Puerto Rico's economic
secretary Manuel Laboy Rivera describes
as key for the future of the island in
Puerto Rico we have over 50,000 small
and medium businesses and the majority
of the jobs that are being created in
Puerto Rico actually come from the small
and medium businesses secretary Rivera's
office is tasked with achieving economic
growth for Puerto Rico hurricane Maria
has complicated his job dramatically
number one create jobs actually
well-paying jobs that will be the focus
number two attract investment to Puerto
Rico a grow local businesses especially
in the technology innovation and exports
areas and of course achieve economic
growth long term how much harder is it
gonna be to do those four
responsibilities to accomplish those
after Hurricane Maria it was a challenge
before you know when we got into office
in January we inherited a very
challenging situation in terms of our
fiscal
side of the government prior to Maria
the island was already struggling with
over seventy billion dollars in
municipal debt and a sharply declining
population what can actually be done I
think there's gonna be like a
combination of different efforts we need
to reinvent I remind ourselves there's
gonna be a percentage of businesses on
the short term that are gonna have a
hard time trying to reopen or trying to
stay in business and we're trying to do
everything that we can from the
government perspective
despite his optimism this secretary
could only answer theoretically but how
the island will move forward
economically is a question few people
have a concrete answer to it's a
question that puts business owners like
Sebastian and then even more precarious
situation than before the storm it does
worry me I know I know I have a lot of
friends that have left the island maybe
it's an opportunity for them to go and
then come back yes which is what I hope
it happens even when I close down the
restaurant I one of the first things I
thought were my employees they most of
them had been working since opening we
were a family the future of the island
both humanitarian and economic is in a
fragile place it has many young people
like Sebastian divided on the question
of whether to stay and tough it out or
leave the island altogether
thanks for watching and please be sure
to subscribe to AJ plus not only for
more videos on Puerto Rico but also more
documentaries just like this be sure to
also check out the rest of the series
where we explore the recovery efforts in
Puerto Rico and we also meet with Puerto
Ricans who are leaving to the US
mainland